what's the first step to writing a
screenplay
for me the um the first step
uh is usually um
[Music]
an idea of plot or story um
i don't really start with a character i
admire people that do that
but i'm very much like um
you know stanislavski kind of outside in
kind of thing
like you know find the shoes and then
you'll find the person as opposed to the
other way around
kind of thing if that makes sense um so
i usually have an idea or a concept or a
story i kind of want to tell and
and in writing it i find the characters
i
find the story and and then when i know
it's working whether that's
on an outline perspective or whether
it's in a draft perspective whether it's
draft one or draft
ten you know when the characters
suddenly start doing things
i don't want them to do then i know i've
got the characters right
and what i mean by that is that um
i can be writing and i can have an
outline and i can have a story and i can
i can know where i'm going
and then that character will just start
to say something
out of my fingers and it will start to
want to go through that door instead of
that door i'm like okay well let's go
there and see what happens
you know and it's i think that's partly
um
you know enjoying being flexible as you
write
you know and partly i think maybe that's
like
my very basic drama acting training in
me
is that i can become those characters i
write them
in a way and i feel that and then
something in my being says well no i
wouldn't do that
you know as that character so it'll be
your plot needs something to do but your
character might not
then you get into that interesting area
of like well okay well let's explore
what's down that corridor what's that
way and
you know we want those characters to go
um
so that that can be interesting that can
be that can be a
really pleasurable side of side of
writing
um and i i love structure
i always start you know with um
i really like save the cat the
controversial
but i feel that if i'm ever stuck or
i'm overwhelmed by like oh god i've
gotta write like 1900 pages here like
how is my how is my idea my concept
which sounds cool
you know as a paragraph you know how
does that actually work as a feature
film
is it worthy enough to be a feature film
um
i do read that book or pick up that book
or you know look at
look at hero's journey or something like
that and i'll find that oh okay well
that's
why that's how i'm gonna tell the story
i may not adhere to it
i you know part of knowing the rules is
breaking the rules if if rules exist
i don't think they do but you know
there's a reason why
people like set up and pay off there's a
reason why
you know going back to the days of you
know telling a story around a campfire
or
you know or at a party you're tying a
good anecdote
you know like you don't suddenly come
out with the ending it's just not it's
not satisfying
there's there's there's we've we've
this idea of structure or the way you
tell stories is kind of somehow
ingrained in us
so you so you need to kind of understand
that or you almost need to
um play with the audience with that
either to
make them feel comfortable or to
completely subvert the thing that they
think is going to happen like you know
like all the big twists that we know
that you know that we can reel off right
now
all came because the or the the
structure or the style of the film was
setting up something we didn't expect
and then it's turned kind of on its head
and that's because
and i'm thinking about the m night
shyamalan sixth sense and that kind of
things
is that because as an audience we're
very astute to structure whether that's
you know whether that's subconsciously
or consciously
um that we always want to try and be one
step ahead
so when a film pulls the rug it's very
satisfying because we're like we didn't
see that coming
i know some people did see things that's
coming i didn't i loved it
you know so um so yeah that's that's how
i would how i would start is
from a concept start to apply
to some sort of structure uh and then
let the characters speak
when you were writing the last showing
did you actually
act out stuart lloyd did you did you
become stuart for a little bit and say
you know what
he wouldn't have said that he would have
done it this way
yeah i did actually there's a lot of um
uh
talking to myself in my office um and
he's quite an angry character
so um more so maybe now maybe because
i've got sleeping kids downstairs
uh i'll i'll act in my head
but um i do like to read things out
especially long dialogue uh monologues
or long passages because
to try and find the flow um like you
know if you're trying to
write how i'm talking right now in a
screenplay it
you know it would not be how you would
expect to write it firstly
i don't put enough full stops or commas
in the way i talk i just go on in a
stream of consciousness
um but if that's the character then
actually talking that out helps you find
that
you know and helps you because there's
nothing worse than that no like all the
characters sound the same
you know um and it's like well why
how how why do they sound the same and
if you can do things like that
like punctuation-wise or flow-wise and
you've acted it out and hopefully you
can find that
um in your through the writing
so in starting with the screenplay you
come up with an idea
so um a projectionist who feels like
he's being replaced
new technologies come in younger younger
workers
he's kind of given this sort of like
throwaway job just to keep them on
and then you kind of develop who he is
his psychology
and then after that what's next
what's the next step well well hopefully
i've got a script by that point
i think it's and and sometimes i
write very detailed outlines sometimes i
can't wait to get started
and i'll write um you know a rough
outline
or even just you know bullet point like
a rough structure and see
how we go you know um
and i know like in like in writing last
showing
um i which seems really fundamental now
to the film he's trying to make
it's kind of filmed within the film but
that whole idea of him wanting to be the
hero
didn't really come about until i started
writing it you know
um it was more like i'm making a film
i'm making a horror film i'm gonna teach
these people a lesson and
you know record it in some kind of weird
sort of snuff movie
style thing um and um
and i can't remember whether he i i
think actually he even got caught i
think he died
he did die actually an early draft he he
actually
was killed but and actually that felt
um too cliche it was like talking that
thing about
you know structure is that that's what
the audience maybe wants
but actually in writing stuart i felt
myself
sympathizing with him more than the
other characters
i think people when people see the film
i think people
see that and actually you know won their
reviews
and i must have paid him a lot of money
to say this
but he's like he said it was like akin
to like one hour photo and robin
williams like he's like a really bad guy
and you don't agree with what he's doing
but you understand what he's doing and
it's a really funny gray area and
there's
tension there now my film is
naught point north one percent of the
wonderful movie that is won our photo
because that's one of my favorites so
that was obviously coming through as
well in in the writing uh
you know it's kind of maybe an homage to
that as well
um but yeah i think when stuart started
talking to me
i realized that he actually felt what he
was doing was right
and it was important to teach these
people a lesson and
he wasn't the bad guy because bad people
don't think they're doing bad things
you know so it's important so it's fun
to explore that and then i thought oh
well
that's interesting because if the film
is commenting on
you know protagonist versus antagonist
relations in itself
and i can get the audience to
um root for stuart as the bad guy
and want him to get away with it then
that's a heck of a lot more interesting
than
bad guy gets killed by the good guy at
the end you know
um and then that changed the fate of one
of the other characters because
obviously
you know in terms of film convention you
know
the bad guy's got to go but if stuart's
not the bad guy
then maybe the bad guy he creates needs
to go um
and maybe it's not the hollywood ending
uh
you know it's an indie so we're allowed
to kind of get away with it um
but i think it's fun um to
let him let the bad guy win sometimes
how do you know you have a great story
well i think
knowing you have a great story start i
think it starts personally i think it's
um i think it just comes from a film
that you want to see
that that feels different or maybe is
trying to say something that you think
is
important to say um
i think i know it's a good story if it
doesn't let me go
like i keep thinking about it and maybe
i'm not even writing it you know
in the kind of life cycle of writing you
know you do the 95
of of writing is just not writing
you know he's thinking he's
procrastinating is he's
avoiding he's torturing yourself that
you should be writing
but they don't let you go and you're on
a dog walk and so you're like oh that's
interesting or you watch something
oh that's actually interesting so like i
mean i've got one right now in my head
that is a really
interesting concept um
because i love to make like an
interstellar kind of a very kind of
um epic but kind of
internal sci-fi kind of movie you know
that that
that makes you think um and
uh so there's something i'm toying with
at the moment that i was basically
reading a book about and i'm not gonna
reveal it because
you know someone better than me or write
it quicker than i can come up with it
but
i wrote something about space travel
about long-term space travel with its
effects it has on the body
um and i thought oh that's a really
interesting
thing that could become a story and that
little seed has now grown into this kind
of character
and this situation but i um
haven't really i haven't watered the
idea enough really it's kind of still
it's still germinating it's still still
growing in my mind
um and maybe i have a spark of
inspiration i'll just want to write it
you know i feel like i'm ready to write
it
um but um whereas some
other ideas you think oh that's a fun
log line
but you're like it's not it's maybe not
great
you know um or what you think is great
maybe there's a fun log line that you
maybe think you could sell i mean that's
another thing
you know um maybe if
you've got quite a commercial idea that
you could sell as a pitch
and then you could make it great being
paid to write it
make it great you know that would be the
inspiration to write it but
i think if you're writing things on spec
they've kind of got to speak to you in
that way that they don't let you go
um and uh yeah there's a few like that
at the moment that are kind of vying for
my attention
in my head that hopefully will i'll
write one day
you